how the [ __ ] do you steal  a job  i've never seen a mexican walk into a  restaurant give me the dishes despite  being dope at crowdwork andrew schultz  is still one of the best joke riders in  the game his secret sauce is being able  to twist his life experiences into  hilarious [ __ ] i worked in restaurants  with these guys who literally would work  18 hours a day seven days a week and now  they're still in the jobs that kind of  stuff like that it just didn't sit right  to me so it was my way of kind of like  defending these people who i didn't  think were stealing jobs i thought they  were doing the american thing first of  all that's the stupidest thing i ever  heard in my life how the [ __ ] do you  steal  a job  i never seen a mexican walk into a  restaurant give me the dishes that [ __ ]  never happened in my [ __ ]  no no we don't want the money rubbing  gloves